[Music]
hello i'm ben wattenberg
in the summer of 1969 hundreds of
thousands of young americans converged
on a farm in upstate new york for the
now
legendary woodstock music and arts fair
did woodstock mark the end of the 60s as
some say
or was it the beginning of a
countercultural revolution that is still
playing itself out in american society
joining us to sort through the conflict
and the consensus are
kurt vonnegut novelist and social critic
and author of more than a score of books
including
slaughterhouse five cats cradle and
breakfast of champions
martha bayless author of whole in our
soul the loss of beauty and meaning in
american popular music
and an editorial consultant for our
program
maurice dickstein professor of english
at the graduate center of the city
university of new york and author of the
gates of eden
american culture in the 60s and jim
miller professor of political science
at the new school for social research
and author of democracy
is in the streets from port euron to the
siege of chicago the question before
this house
did woodstock change america this week
on
think tank
[Music]
in 1969 close to a half a million
self-described hippies
flower children and aquarians made a
pilgrimage
to woodstock in upstate new york by the
time we got to woodstock
the woodstock music and arts festival
was called an aquarian exposition and
hailed as three days of peace and music
and it was peaceful but the times were
not
america seemed to be dividing the war in
vietnam went on
and on more american boys were still
being sent to southeast asia
by newly elected president nixon the
increasingly
unpopular war intensified a campus
protest movement
burning draft cards and peace marches
became daily fair on the
evening news and not all the
demonstrations were peaceful
the previous summer after martin luther
king was assassinated
riots broke out in 125 cities
and at the democratic convention in
chicago the anti-war
movement tore the democratic party in
two
both critics and fans concede that
woodstock has become part of the
mythology of the 1960s
even if the actual event didn't
necessarily represent
the musical or political taste of most
young americans at the time
some say it symbolized the freedom and
idealism of the 1960s
critics argue that woodstock represented
much of what was wrong with the 60s
a glorification of drugs a loosening of
sexual morality
and a socially corrosive disrespect for
authority
25 years later the debate still rages
about the meaning of woodstock and more
importantly
about the legacy of those who attended
it in person
or in spirit
[Music]
uh martha bayless
welcome welcome to you all what happened
at uh at woodstock what is is woodstock
a legitimate symbol of the 60s of the
counterculture
i think woodstock is laden with a lot of
symbolic meaning and that's why we're
arguing about it and we still
talk about it but the meanings are
numerous
woodstock was a was a mixed bag
to the hardcore left at in 1969
woodstock was nothing but a rock concert
it wasn't a demonstration
and a lot of people criticize it on that
basis
nowadays when woodstock is being
compared to the highly commercialized
woodstock 94
it's seen as a sort of pure spontaneous
in gathering of
of of free spirits practicing peace and
love
when in fact it was a commercial venture
it was a rock concert and
without the profit motive and the
presence of popular recording stars it
probably wouldn't have happened anyway
um but there were some very positive
things things that positive about the
60s and some negative things we're going
to come back to that uh
jim miller what what about the uh the
woodstock concert
is that was that the apogee of something
was it the beginning of a slide
well the way i think that myths get
hatched in the united states is always a
strange mixture of reality and
imagination
as a concert pair say i don't even it
wasn't that important in terms of the
large scale history of rock and roll
i think that the fact that it happened
in new york city that the media were
close to it
magnified it out of all proportion and
once it had been so magnified
it became a symbol for all kinds of
people it became an
image in the minds of people who weren't
there of a way that you could experience
music as a cultural lifestyle
it became an a further emblem to the
music industry that there was a market
that they still had yet to fully tap
and uh in the immediate sequel to
woodstock there were numerous attempts
to catch
they both stressed a certain commercial
aspect to this yes
and the third thing i would say is that
in the long haul it has become a
convenient symbol for people who are
hostile to what the spirit of the 60s
whatever that represents
it's become a convenient symbol for them
and a target
uh so for conservatives to be against
woodstock yeah yeah uh
morris morris stixteen well woodstock
was commercial but after all it was a
commercial disaster that was only
recouped by the movie
and it's the movie that as well as some
media coverage but mainly the movie i
think that turned woodstock into the
enduring
myth that it later became uh so many
people think they were at woodstock but
they really only saw the movie uh
and uh that's like that famous story of
how many people
uh claim they saw babe ruth point to uh
to to
to hitting the the home run how few
people voted for nixon how a few people
but uh the uh
it didn't really represent all of the
60s it represented those strands of the
counterculture rather than the political
side of the 60s but it had its own
politics because as your
introductory piece said it took place in
the context of the war so all those days
of
peace and love amid chaos and
disorganization
really was a way of acting out a kind of
lifestyle protest against
the wars assassinations and the whole
violence side of the
60s it tends to get stressed more and
and media stereotypes
kurt vonnegut you were uh one of the
cultural icons
at that time i like it or not i never
showed myself to my
people and i had
i had uh four kids
uh who were proper age to go to
woodstock
and they simply were not interested
although they were
pacifists and outraged at the government
and so forth
they were attracted to peace marches to
set-ins to teach-ins
and political demonstrations and
we were talking just in the green room
about how much i missed abby hoffman
he was a great man he was a youthful man
for
focusing attention on the outrages
many outrages it meant many injustices
and nuttinesses
in our society and uh woodstock did none
of that i guess it
was it was used you said it was
politically useful one of the reasons
why there's this
flowery lovely myth about woodstock is
because it was
compared to some of the other things
that were going on in 1969
rather benign um in 1969 sds had split
into
the students for democratic society
which was the
hard left of the student movement it was
the student political
organization it split into the
weatherman faction which was
um rather they were kind of terrorist
wannabes at that point i mean they were
very hung up on
the idea of whether they could commit
violence i think partly because
they knew people their own age were
fighting and dying in vietnam and
and that was a problem for them and it
was partly because of the black movement
which they
very much were copying and emulating was
very much
out of its out of its non-violent and
into its violent stage i think one
person so woodstock was a
a lot of kids at woodstock were not into
that kind of politics and as a result
they weren't into politics especially at
all
i think one problem was that those
benign images i think angered a lot of
people in middle america more
than even the images of protest i think
there were some people
inspired by images of all this uh
sex and love and free
especially the peaceful atmosphere of
woodstock the idea of
of childlike innocence i think inspired
some people with the desire to kill
you know inspired at least other people
with i think it probably is the ancestor
of our culture wars today because
what we think of as the move towards
fundamentalism the new wright family
values really did emerge as a reaction
to that counter-cultural ethos in the
60s but
one of the things i think that comes up
when you look at the it's interesting at
the public opinion polls today is that
the american people are afraid or many
of the american people are afraid that
bill
and hillary clinton sort of represent
quotes the 60s
or that part of part of them bill
clinton was the guy running for class
president then he was not the guy
yeah but he was also allegedly dodging
the draft and doing a few other
and not inhaling and a few other things
i mean you know it's it's a it's a
complex story
this brings up the third thing that
woodstock was
it was it was a rock concert it was not
a political demonstration
what it really was though on another
level was it
it was a something that's deeply in the
american grain it was kind of a revival
meeting
and there was a quality about woodstock
that smacked of the outdoor camp meeting
the methodist camp meeting
why has this hung on as a
as a symbol is that how things work i
mean
times get sort of uh attached to a
specific event and
i think it represents a very primitive
need in
all of us uh which is seldom
acknowledged
is i think our peril we do without
vitamin c for instance
at our peril we do without a tribe
without a
without a support system a nuclear
family is not a support system it's
hideously vulnerable
and so we again and again
join gangs is for most of the seven
million years they've been human beings
we have lived in families of 50 or 100.
now the people who talk about family
values dan quayle for instance from my
hometown
he has an extended family he might as
well be an ebo
in nigeria he has lawyers
been cousins i mean that is a compliment
yes no everybody should have what he
should all be so fortunate and when
somebody like quail talks about
family values yeah we'd like to have
families too as most of us don't but
he's got one
and in fact it was called i mean the
whole thing was called the movement
yeah that was an extended family the
funny thing about that period though is
there are so many events that mark the
period where
not just an extended family but three
four five hundred thousand people got
together and
no matter what happened whether it was
the music being played that very few
people could hear because of the bad
sound system or whether it was the
political demonstration in washington
where nobody listened to the speeches
but just being there was the thing
there was a sense of of a larger
community and we may think of it as a
very thin idea of community
but it was a sense of an alienated part
of the culture a youth culture that had
been building at least since catcher in
the rye 20 years earlier
getting together and asserting itself
with its various generational anthems
and
and that was a key element in creating
that sense of of a support system that
that kurt just mentioned that strikes me
that there's another dark side of this
that's worth
bringing in uh to the picture here which
is just a few days before woodstock it's
worth remembering
the family that murdered sharon tate
and that charlie manson was a version of
what could come out of this kind of
pseudo pseudo-tribalism
in a drug-addled atmosphere exactly and
that there's a way in which
woodstock i wonder how the media would
have played it if they had known
at the time which they didn't that
manson was in his own way as legitimate
a hippie as anybody who went to
woodstock let me uh ask ask questions
i sort of come out of the the political
uh
uh arena and uh in fact
i had during that vietnam war i had
worked on president johnson's staff so
we come from rather different
different backgrounds the how
representative
of american young people were
the people at woodstock or even the
woodstock nation
i mean i'll just cite a couple of uh
poll results from the time that i recall
which was that
young people were more pro-vietnam war
than adults were
young people were more pro-george
wallace than adults were
and in 1972 in that general general era
a majority of young people voted against
george mcgovern and for richard nixon
so uh how
was this uh typical america was this
or are we talking about a thin elite
fringe that got the media attention
it is a function of education there's
ignorant people
like me right
no these were educated people they were
middle class i think you'd be attacked
on class grounds probably is who they
were
well i count a cultural middle class
also i mean there's a book called
woodstock nation that shows that
ninety-three percent of the catholic
culture were middle class
uh uh the i think that the
the i think the fallacy there is a
numbers game i mean they're always a lot
of people
uh who are living the way their parents
lived in the way their grandparents
lived it's just that i think a fairly
large part of that generation that
boomer generation was
uh represented uh some form of
alienation whether radical or mild and
so on really represented a sense of
having different values from their
parents who were the world war ii
generation or the 40s and 50s
generation and it's that generation that
try to assert itself
let's try to move on now from the event
of woodstock
to the consequences of of woodstock and
let me see if i can
try it out uh in a provocative way what
we saw at woodstock and from the 60s
among other things
was the drug culture was sexual
promiscuity
uh and we could argue about this was
pacifism
and i would say that if we had remained
a or became
a pacifist uh nation we would not have
won the cold war
much to the dismay of people around the
world so
what um what are the consequences of
woodstock
i think it was a failed project because
a lot of young people believed in peace
and love but they didn't have a very
good guide as to what peaceful or loving
actions
really were and they were it was very
much about personal liberation
and not very much about how to treat
other people how to treat other people
became a very confused and and chaotic
issue for a lot of young people even if
they weren't a woodstock or they weren't
at the extremes
there was a lot of moral confusion and
by moral confusion i mean
how to treat other people and uh
if you add in the toxic emotions that
are that are brought about by drug abuse
you have a recipe for for for real
disaster
and and people who felt mistreated by
their friends and their lovers and so
forth in the 60s
were always accused of having middle
class hang-ups you know
hey you know what's your problem why why
do you object to what i just did to you
you know you're just hung up on middle
class morality and that affected a lot
of people i don't know what the polls
how the polls would measure that but
that affected a lot of carter
are we a better country because of the
60s
today yes
i think so uh that the 60s
taught us that we can build an extended
family and unify
ourselves uh with music
feminism did not come out of the 60s
is i talked to any number of women who
were
the right age to be involved who were
treated abominably as slaves as
as gophers well i sum it up this way in
the 60s men liberated themselves from
the demands made on them traditionally
by women
in the 70s women liberated themselves
from the demands traditionally made by
men
on the same model that the men had used
and the tragedy is that they both blacks
have used
they both liberated themselves from the
demands made by children i would say
that the big split
is between the people with sensitive
humor and people
as you know yes it's
all has to go on this way you know it's
real world politics
and we have we have this example of a
of a country being able to go absolutely
nuts in germany
and so we could start that way it was
these uh
military adventures and uh are you
talking about now
no oh yeah no no i'm talking about the
vietnam war which was finally
it had to be brought to an end somehow
well the
i i would describe it a little
differently it was woodstock represented
a failed utopianism that
very easily got commercialized and i
think very easily got turned into style
and you know
what happened i mean the people who are
in their own way protesting
the war and other things at woodstock
were were
were acting out a criticism not by going
to the ballot box but by the way they
would dress
the clothes they wore various kinds of
mores that got
the label lifestyle later on and the
counterculture
unlike the new left the counterculture
was very amenable to being turned into
something that could easily be
commercialized
i think i really disagree with you i
think actually i would put it almost the
other way around that the new left
which i've written a book about i think
ultimately isn't that important
politically
and it didn't have that great an impact
except indirectly by sparking a middle
class peace movement
the counter culture precisely because it
was picked up and shoved
into the marketplace spread the ethos of
the 60s
in the early 70s and in the process of
what you're
i think denigrating a style or fashion
actually changed the culture
and changed it in ways for example our
sexual morality
it changed sexual mores it changed
attitudes towards
authority it changed
a sense of what was permissible to
experiment with what
limits could be toyed with what drove
them home in american culture
was the marketing uh through rock and
roll among other things through film
of a certain fantasy of freedom
that to me has a connection say with
randolph-born
early progressive bohemians but it
becomes a massive
artifact what did what did it do to our
music
well i think i agree with jim um i think
that our commercial
system has the ability to amplify
magnify and multiply and popularize any
cultural change
and this does make the counterculture
different from previous forms of
bohemianism it became a mass phenomenon
which morris has written about marketing
it's not just the marketing i think what
happened is that it's in that original
reaction to woodstock and the
counterculture middle america looked at
that
with a combination of hostility and envy
not young middle america well no i think
they did i think that
in one sense they felt that the
traditional values
were threatened by by the new morris
represented by the counter culture in
another sense they thought
god i wish i were young now or i wish i
were involved in this it was a kind of
a a sexual deep sexual fantasy and
fantasy of freedom involved that was
part of the marketing and so on
and what happened is that gradually this
was shorn of any political context it
might have had
and entirely personalized and turned
into the kind of transformation of
cultural worries that you described let
me return to that
political context for a moment the the
the component
parts of the so-called the movement one
could say it
started with the civil rights and then
it uh accumulated uh
feminism and environmentalism and
consumerism and now more would be the
and the peace movement who would accept
here the idea that there was
some good in each one of those movements
i would wait wait a minute wait a minute
but
they each went too far everything that
makes an impact goes too far
in other words things that are moderate
and easy and so and do not really make
an impact
what happens is that some there's some
transformational push
and eventually a lot of it drops away
and doesn't really have its effect but
some of it sticks and
becomes part of this permanent cultural
change that jim was describing and i
think every one of those
uh movements that you described had that
effect currently did it go too far
did these movements go too far no i i
would like to
uh see them all uh so many of them go
much farther it's in
environmentalism for instance which you
mentioned
uh and so i think you're right
it's it's uh a movement is a failure
really
if it doesn't go too far if i look back
on what i think is good about the 60s
from my own perspective
that of a of a white person with a
privileged background okay
one of the nice things about the 60s and
positive things about the 60s was it
encouraged you to pay serious attention
to what life was like for the people on
the other side of the tracks
the way it went too far was a lot of the
radical political part of the movement
had fantasies about those people and
never uh
really understood them very well and and
particularly with blacks
this incredible fantasy of blacks is as
violent and
super alienated as this panther fantasy
that the left had
i think has been extremely destructive
uh
try to sum up for us and for our
audience uh
what do you all agree upon and what do
you disagree upon
i think everything that we look back to
the 60s and think about including the
counterculture
has its has its upside his positive side
in terms of the liberation the easing
the relaxing of american moires
that we many of us grew up with in the
1950s and also has
its side in which it went too far in
other words
the sense the sense that it unleashed
all sorts of demons that that we see
today in the culture wars
kurt what do we uh agree upon what do we
disagree upon well
i i think that probably an important
movement was going
invisibly in the universities in the
coffee houses
among among intelligent people prepared
to
do political work and so concerts really
had nothing to do with it but
it seems after the fact an awful lot
of important devoted thinking
has come out of the 60s relative to
rescuing the planet
to questioning authority on military uh
adventures and so forth and so we have
as we as we prepare to invade haiti yes
i'm ready i'm going
and there was a skepticism that can't be
put aside
yeah but the the uh i think it happened
in in the souls of many of us and of
course those are invisible
uh jen above all else an
experiment in living that was shared and
collective
not shared by everybody like a real
experiment
we learned through mistakes but to speak
just for myself i would do it all over
again
martha i think last shot i think we
agree there were
we agreed there were angels with stock
and also devils and
we may not we may disagree somewhat
about which was which
all right uh thank you martha bayless
jim miller maurice dickstein and kurt
vonnegut
and thank you we are very happy to hear
from our viewers
please send any comments or questions to
the address
on the screen
for think tank i'm ben wattenberg
[Music]
this has been a production of bjw
incorporated
in association with new river media
which are solely responsible for its
content